hi there today we're going to look at
curl contrastive unsupervised
representations for reinforcement
learning by Aravind Sreenivas Michel
Laskin and Petra Biel so this is a
general framework for unsupervised
representation learning for our L so
let's untangle the title a little bit it
is for reinforcement learning which it
if you don't know what reinforcement
learning is I've done a bunch of videos
on are L afraid works so it's for
general reinforcement learning that
means it can be paired with almost any
RL algorithm out there so we're not
going to you know dive into specific or
allowed rooms today it is unsupervised
which means it doesn't need any sort of
labels and it also doesn't need a reward
signal forum RL which is pretty cool
because usually the entire RL pipelines
rely on some sort of a reward or
auxiliary reward signal now there is a
training objective here but it doesn't
have to do with the RL reward and then
in the it is learning representations
which means it learns it learns
intermediate representations of the
input data that is useful and in the end
it is contrastive and that is the the
kind of secret sauce in here the
training objective it's what's called
contrastive learning and that's what
we're going to spend most of our time on
today exploring what that means alright
so here's the general framework you can
see it down here sorry about that so you
can see that reinforcement learning is
just a box which is we don't care about
the RL algorithm you use that's just you
know what what comes at the end what
comes at the beginning oh here is the
observation so the observation in an RL
algorithm is kind of fundamental now if
someone explains RL to you or
reinforcement learning usually what
they'll say is there is some kind
of actor and there is some kind of
environment right and the environment
will give you an observation right
observation Oh which is some sort of
let's say here is an image right so in
this in this RL framework specifically
the examples they give are of image
based reinforcement learning so let's
say the Atari game where you have this
little spaceship here and there are
meteorites up here and you need to shoot
them so there is a little shot here
right you need to shoot those meteorites
right so this is the observation oh and
then as an age as an actor you have to
come up with some sort of action and the
actions here can be something like moved
to the left move to the right press the
button that you know does the shooting
so you have to come up with an action
somehow given this observation and then
the environment will give you back a
reward along with the next observation
like the next frame of the game and
you're gonna have to come up with
another action in response to that and
the environments going to give you back
another reward and the next observation
and so on so what you want to do is you
want to find a mapping from observation
to action such that your reward is going
to be as high as possible right this is
the fundamental problem of RL and
usually what people do is they take this
act this mapping here from observation
to action to be some sort of function
some sort of function that is
parameterised maybe and nowadays of
course it's often a neural network but
you're trying to learn given the input
observation what output action you need
to do and you can think of the same here
so you have this input observation up
here and down here after the
reinforcement learning the output is
going to be an action right and so this
this function we talked about up here is
usually implemented sorry is usually
implement
as you put the observation into the r.l
framework and then the RL framework
learns this f of theta function to give
you an action now here you can see the
pipeline is a bit different we don't
want to shove the observation in
directly right we don't want the
observation directly but what we put
into the RL framework is this Q thing
now the Q is supposed to be a
representation of the observation and a
useful representation so if we think of
this of this game here of this Atari
game up here what could be the what
could be a useful representation if if I
had to craft one by hand how would I
construct a useful representation keep
in mind the representation the goal is
to have a representation of the
observation that is more useful to the
RL algorithm than just the pure pixels
of the image right so if I have to craft
a representation let's say it's a vector
right let's say our our our
representations need to be vectors what
I would do is I would probably take the
x and y coordinates of the little
spaceship right x and y and put it in
the vector that's pretty useful and then
I would probably take the x and y
coordinates of the meteorites that are
around right let's say there are maximum
two XY XY here I would probably take the
angle right the angle where my spaceship
is pointing to that should be pretty
useful because if I shoot I want to know
where I shoot right so theta here and
then probably maybe the X and y
coordinate of the of the shot here of
the red shot that I fired if there is
one right also going to put that into my
representation so x and y and maybe
Delta X Delta Y something like this
right so you can see if I had to
handcraft something if I I can pretty
much guarantee
that if I put in this representation
right here into the RL algorithm but put
this in here it would turn out
guaranteed it would turn out to be a
better or L agent that learns faster
than if I put in the original
observation which is the the pixel image
of the game right because of course in
order to play the game correctly in
order to play the game to win you need
to extract this information right you
need to get our there's something like a
spaceship there's something like
meteorites this is all things that are
elegant doesn't know her say and would
have to learn from the pixels right but
if I already give it the information
that is useful it can learn much faster
all right so you can see if I handcraft
a good representation it's pretty easy
for the RL algorithm to improve now we
want to come up with a framework that
automatically comes up with a good
representation right so it alleviates
the RL algorithm here that reinforcement
it alleviates that from learn from
having to learn a good representation
right it already is burdened with
learning the what a good action is in
any given situation right we want to
alleviate it of the burden to also
extract useful information from the from
the observation space right so how do we
do this this is Q here is supposed to be
exactly that it's supposed to be a good
representation but not one that we
handcrafted but a used with a technique
that can be employed pretty much
everywhere and the goal sorry that the
secret sauce here is this contrastive
loss thing okay
this bombed contrastive learning is this
this kind of magic thing that will make
us good representations so what is
contrastive learning in this case I'm
going to explain
in this case for this kind of image
based for image based reinforcement
learning but just for image based neural
networks how can we come up with a
contrastive loss so you see there's kind
of a two pipeline thing going on here
there is like this and this and then one
of them is going to be the good encoding
all right so let's check it out let's
say we have this image that we had
before right draw it again this little
spaceship this and this and so right and
we want to we want to do this what we
need to do is we need to produce three
different things from it we need to
produce an anchor what's called an
anchor so we need to produce a positive
sample positive sample and we need to
produce negative samples let's just go
with one negative sample for now right
so the goal is to come up with a task
that where we produce our own labels
right so we want since we're training a
encoder and the encoder is a neural
network that's parametrized we need some
sort of loss function so the goal is to
come up with a method where we can
create our own labels to a task but that
we construct the task in a way such that
the neural network has no choice but
learn something meaningful even though
we made the task of ourselves all right
I hope this was kind of clear so how are
we gonna do this our method of choice
here is going to be random cropping now
random cropping means that I just I take
an image right and I crop a a piece from
it so a smaller piece from the image I
just take a view inside the image
so in case of the anchor right I'm gonna
draw the same picture here bear with me
I'm gonna draw the same picture here a
couple of times this is all supposed to
be the same picture and with the
negative sample I'm just gonna leave it
empty for now there are two meteorites
two meteorites shot shot right so for
the anchor we're going to actually not
random crop but center crop right so
we're going to take here the center
image right so the assumption is kind of
that if I Center if I Center crop I
won't lose you know too much of the
image I can actually make the crop
bigger such that almost everything of
the image is somewhat contained in this
and that yeah all right so this is going
to be my anchor and then the positive
sample is going to be a random crop of
the same image so I'm just randomly
going to select a same size same size
section from that image let's say this
is up right here all right and the
negative sample is going to be around
the crop from a different image right so
a different image might be from the same
game right but might be there is a
meteorite here right and there is no
shot I don't I don't shoot and I'm going
to take a random crop from this let's
say I'm going to take a random crop here
let's put a meteorite here as well just
for fun all right so these are going to
be our three samples and now the
question is going to be if I give the
anchor to the neural network I'm going
to say I give you the anchor right but
I'm also going to give you this and this
thing and I'm not going to give
any of this I'm just going to give
whatever I cropped right so just just
these things so I asked the neural
network neural network I give you the
anchor now which one of these two which
one of these two crops comes from the
same image right so as human you look at
this and if you just see the center crop
you see oh okay down here there's this
this tip of this thing and then there's
the shot right and in relation to the
shot there is a meteor here right and
then you look at the second one and you
say okay I don't see the spaceship but
there's the same relation here from the
shot to the meteor and I can kind of see
the meteor up here and this also fits
with that right and the the spaceship
must be you know down here somewhere and
then I go over here and I try to do the
same thing is okay here's the meteor and
you know it it might be it might be in
the original image it might be over here
somewhere so that's possible I don't see
it right that's possible but then there
should be there should be a shot right
somewhere here or sorry further up
oops T there should be a shot somewhere
here right I'm pretty sure because
there's there's one over here and I
don't see it right so I am fairly sure
mr. tasks asked her that this image here
is the positive sample while this image
here is the negative sample right so
this is the task that you ask of the
neural network give it the anchor and
you ask which one of the of these two
comes from the same image right this is
called contrastive learning now is a bit
more complicated in that of course what
you do is you encode these things using
neural networks and then
so each of the things you encode so the
anchor you're going to encode all of
these things using a neural network
right and then this is what's going to
become the query and these are becoming
the keys so key one or key two and then
you're going to feed it always two of
them into a bilinear product right the
bilinear product is simply you can think
of it as an inner product in a perturbed
space that you can learn so you're going
to have this you have these two here
these go into q WK one and then these
two here sorry this and this go into q w
k 2 now W here is a learnable parameter
right so you have some freedom and then
you basically take whichever one of
those two is highest right so this might
be this high and this might only be this
high and then you say aha cool this
one's higher so this one must be the
positive right and you train the W
specifically to make this higher to make
the positive ones higher and the
negative ones a lower so this is a
supervised learning task right where
these things here are going to be the
lockets or or the so their inner product
but you basically then pick the one that
is highest as a in a soft max way and
they put this in the paper so if we go
down here the objective that they use to
do the contrastive learning is this one
so as you can see it's a soft max like
in multi-class classification of the
inner product the bilinear product with
the positive samples over the bilinear
product with the positive samples plus
the bilinear product with all of the
negative samples so you're going to come
up with more than one negative sample
all right now the only thing left that
we don't have here is that the encoding
how you're going to come from the image
space to this space here is going to be
slightly different and depending on
whether you're talking on the anchor or
on the what what are called the keys the
things you compare to and this is out of
a kind of a stability criterion you
already maybe you don't you know like
something like double q-learning or
things like this it sometimes when you
train with your own thing so in
q-learning you're kind of trying to to
come up with an actor and a critic or
it's not the same thing but you're kind
of using the same neural network twice
in in your in your setup and then you
compare the output stored to each other
which isn't you know it leads to
instability so in our case we took it
three times here or multiple times
especially for the same objective here
we have twice something that was encoded
by the same neural networking isn't the
two sides of this by linear product so
if we were to use the same neural
network that tends to be somewhat
unstable so we have different neural
networks one that will encode the query
which is this F Q + 1 which will encode
the keys sorry F ok now we don't want to
learn to neural networks and that's why
there's a bit of a compromise where we
say it is the same neural network but
but basically this one is the one we
learn and then we always every now and
then we transfer over the parameters to
that one and in fact each step we
transfer over the parameters and do an
exponential moving average
with the parameters of this momentum
encoder from the step before so the
momentum encoder parameters are a moving
average of the parameters of the query
encoder and that is so you get kind of
get the best of both worlds you don't
have to learn a second neural network
but your second neural network is not
the same as your first neural network
but it it kind of lags behind but it is
also it is also performing almost as
well so that is um I don't know if that
makes sense but it is the best I can to
explain it so to recap you take your
observation you encode it as a query
sorry you crop crop here for your anchor
that gets your query and then you random
crop for your keys right into positive
and negative samples right so random
crop from the same observation or from
different observations right these
become your positive and negative
samples then you take you take me push
this through your encoders for the query
and for the keys respectively you end up
with the Q which is the encoded anchor
and the case which are the encoded
positive and negative samples and then
you learn you update this encoder here
using the contrastive loss right and at
the same time you feed the q you feed
the q here into the reinforcement
learning algorithm and you learn your
reinforcement learning algorithm instead
of giving having the observation
directly as an input here you now have
the Q here as an input right that is it
the reinforcement learning works exactly
the same but except having the
so input Oh you now have the
representation input queue and you don't
have to worry about anything else in
terms of the reinforcement learning
algorithm it stays exactly the same
right the this whole thing here can
actually run either in parallel or you
can think of it before you can think of
it off policy on policy it is sort of
modular how you how you fit this in it
simply comes up with good
representations so that is that is
basically a deal here right and you hope
that the whole procedure of this
contrastive learning then gives you good
representation of this anchor thing here
if you encode that to the queue you hope
that this representation now is a good
representation as a basis for the RL
algorithm and it turns out at least in
their experiments it is so here you see
the same thing they actually they do
something more where in RL usually deal
with a stack of observations not just a
single observation because so for
example in Atari people always
concatenate something like for the four
last frames right and their their point
is okay if we have this stack here if we
do this data augmentation you know these
crops we kind of need to do them
consistently right we need to crop every
single image at the same point for the
query and also if we do a random crop
let's say a random crop down here we
need to do this same random crop for all
of the of the stack of images here right
so um that that is kind of the
additional thing they introduced it with
respect to RL that deals with with
stacked time frames but it's kind of the
same the same diagram as above here
right so they explained the the RL
algorithms they use and exactly they're
they're their thing and here you can see
that anchor is a crop
and the positive sample is a random crop
from the same image this would be up
here somewhere the anchor is cropped
from the middle and then the negative
would be a random crop from a different
image or a different stack of images
they have a pseudo code here where that
was pretty simple
we'll just go through it quickly right
you start off with fq + FK these are the
encoders for the query and keys you
start them off the same then you go
through your data loader you do this
random augmentation of your query and
you keys and I don't not even sure if
the random augmentation needs actually
to be a central crop for the anchor or
just two different two different crops
from the same image that might be as
well so you know just I guess I guess
it's a thing you could choose I don't
know what exactly is the best thing
alright then I forward the query through
the FQ and I forward the keys through
the FK then important I detach this so I
don't train I don't want to train the FK
I only want to train the FQ right then I
do the bilinear product here with the W
these these are the bilinear product and
then I put this all of this into a cross
entropy loss right in the end I update
my fq m IW and i do this exponentially
moving average for my key encoder and
they test on two different things they
test on the deepmind control tasks and
they always test 100 K time steps so
their big point is data efficiency right
they they claim they can use learn
useful representations with not much
data so the task is here how good are
you at one
100 cases that time steps right so you
don't you don't optimize until the end
you just you get 100k time steps and
then the question is how how good are
you and the curl here outperforms all of
the baselines handily in the deep mind
control tasks and it also outperforms a
lot of the baselines in the Atari tasks
and it actually if you look at the
results it doesn't outperform everything
but for example here the red is curl and
the dashed gray is state as a si
now state si si the important thing to
note here is it has access to the state
whereas curl only works from pixels
right so that what I said before like if
I had to craft the use for a
presentation basically state si si has
access to that and you see that in many
of the tasks that the curl comes close
or performs equally well to the state si
si right so that's pretty impressive
especially if you've took at pixel si si
sorry which is the same algorithm but
does not have access to the state just
the pixels it often fails terribly right
so um that is pretty interesting to see
and even to me it's pretty interesting
to see that this kind of this kind of
algorithm this kind of self labeled
algorithm comes up with such useful
representations all right so I hope I
have explained this satisfactorily and
check out the paper for more experiments
ablation studies and just general
reading and I wish you a good day